i'm here to present the oscar for best
actress
the academy has recognized some
outstanding performances this year
25 years ago she made her broadway debut
in an august wilson play
tonight viola davis is nominated for
bringing to life
another of that great american
playwright's work as the lead actress in
ma
rainey's black bottom you were luminous
in that role viola
andrew day it's hard to believe the
united states versus billie holiday is
your first major film role
you seamlessly embodied the icon and
reminded us that billie holiday was a
survivor and a fighter
vanessa kirby you went there for your
performance in pieces of a woman
which is why your peers have recognized
this fearless and vulnerable performance
francis mcdormand in this untethered
moment we needed your performance in
nomad land
you took us into a world hiding in plain
sight with charisma and endearing
transparency
carrie mulligan you knew the risk you
were taking with promising young woman
congratulations on a performance that
was painful witty and powerful
and the oscar for best actress goes to
francis mcdormand
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look they didn't ask me but if they had
i would have said karaoke
because when you got voices like leslie
and
marcus and you know that we should add a
karaoke bar
okay i have no words
my voice is in my sword
we know the sword is our work
and i like work thank you for knowing
that
and thanks for this
you